the former British Army intelligence and
security officer Philip Ingram okay
let's uh talk our viewers all through
this Philip so much happening
um the Wagner group group's involvement
it reaches further than than Ukraine has
I mean how important is that well hugely
further than Ukraine and it's very
important indeed you know we've got
Russia Russian influence in the dark red
Ukraine there but Wagner are also in
Syria Libya the Central African Republic
Mali Mozambique and they're controlling
a lot of the natural resources that are
there diamonds gold working into
governments to support corrupt
governments and and piling off money and
all of that money is going up into
Moscow into Vladimir Putin and into the
oligarchs over there and progosian with
his Wagner group are helping to
facilitate that that's important in the
moment whenever there are sanctions
stopping a lot of these oligarchs from
being able to move the money around in
their bank accounts they need these
valuable assets the Diamonds the gold
and all the rest of it so it puts
pregosium in a very powerful position
I didn't realize quite how fast
widespread it was where does a Italy
Wagner in the current situation in
Ukraine then well in Ukraine your Wagner
were fighting into backwood they'd been
fighting for about 18 months into there
we've talked about it continuously
um about a 42 square kilometer area at
uh seven kilometers long it took them 18
months to capture all of that yesterday
they did sort of 800 kilometers in in a
day but they're not in um Ukraine
anymore
um they they had handed over at the end
of May beginning of June moved out to
try and build their capability up again
and then yesterday they did that piece
into Russell Von Dom
um as we heard earlier the um
counterfeit the Ukrainian
counter-offensive is still going on
we're getting an attack into the north
of backward from the ukrainians that's
one of the access that they've got in
down to the um south of Donetsk and
they're trying to get through the
donetsk's zaparizio oblast Border you're
always trying to attack through a border
and then another attack going down from
zapper
trying to split that land bridge and the
the critical lines of communication that
there are there that's been going on
today what's happened the last couple of
days hasn't really affected what's been
going on in the front line right okay
and let's talk about the wider impact
then
um what impact does this have on Ukraine
and Russia going forwards well the
interesting thing is there's a lot we
don't know and we have to put that into
perspective and when you start to
examine a lot of what happened yesterday
you know here we've got progression
sitting in this Southern military
command headquarters talking to the
deputy defense minister Russia's Deputy
defense minister I'm the deputy
commander of the gru the first
directorate Russian military
intelligence who helped form Wagner at
the very beginning it's part of a video
it's still from a video it wasn't an
aggressive meeting it was a strong
business meeting this wasn't someone
who'd captured an area with it with it
with a fight and he was being held
account or people that he had taken
prisoner and remember the FSB Russia's
Security Service had issued an arrest
warrant for progression by then this
looks as if there was um some
understanding of cooperation that had
been going on beforehand so I think this
is one big question of who was behind it
and supporting progosian the whole way
through and therefore how is that the
play out as we look at where it's going
in the future